Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. I can't spell it right. So you just give a fake name, your cafe name, Julia. But the more you use it, the more it feels like you're in witness protection. Wait a minute. What kind of espresso drinks does Julia like anyway? Is it too late to change your latte order? But with an espresso machine by KitchenAid, you wouldn't be thinking any of this because you could have just made your espresso at home.
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。我总是拼不对。所以你随便给个假名字，比如你咖啡馆的名字，朱莉娅。但你用得越多，就越觉得自己在接受证人保护。等等。朱莉娅到底喜欢喝什么样的浓缩咖啡？现在改拿铁订单还来得及吗？但如果有一台 KitchenAid 浓缩咖啡机，你就不会有这些顾虑了，因为你完全可以在家自制浓缩咖啡。
Shop now at KitchenAid.ca. If only he hadn't taken it into his head to dig in a sleepy backwater village for Troy's walls and somehow found them. If he hadn't knelt in the dirt all day with beautiful Sophia, chipping away crust from the tiles of Priam's palace, from bracelets that had once circled the slim wrists of princesses. If he hadn't proven that his dream was graspable, that the stories he loved were fashioned in the high style, not to escape the world, but to remember it, a tribute to the dead, to the dead bright ones whose gestures,
立即前往 KitchenAid.ca 选购。要是他当初没有突发奇想，去那个沉睡的偏僻村庄挖掘特洛伊城墙，并阴差阳错地找到了它们，该多好。要是他没有整天和美丽的索菲亚跪在泥土里，从普里阿摩斯宫殿的瓷砖上，从曾经环绕在公主纤细手腕上的手镯上，一点点凿掉外壳，该多好。要是他没有证明他的梦想是可以实现的，证明他所热爱的故事并非为了逃避世界，而是为了铭记世界，为了向死者致敬，向那些光辉的死者致敬——他们的姿态，
vivid as they are in song, were doubtless in the flesh more dazzling. So that was a poem about Heinrich Schliemann by the American poet Carl Davis. And right there, Tom, you have this sort of sense of the dead bright ones, more dazzling, more terrifying in the flesh than they were in reality. And as that poem suggests, Schliemann's great fame, we ended the last episode by talking about this German archaeologist who is famous for having, in inverted commas, discovered Troy. His fame is bound up with the idea, isn't it, that the stories we talked about last time are true,
正如歌中所唱的那样生动，在现实中无疑更加耀眼。以上是美国诗人卡尔·戴维斯（Carl Davis）关于海因里希·施里曼（Heinrich Schliemann）的一首诗。汤姆，就在这里，你感受到了那种“光辉的死者”的意味，他们在现实中比在传说中更加耀眼，也更加令人恐惧。正如那首诗所暗示的，施里曼的巨大名声——我们在上一集结尾谈到了这位德国考古学家，他因“发现”了特洛伊（加引号）而闻名。他的名声与一个观念紧密相连，不是吗？那就是我们上次谈到的那些故事是真实的，
that there was a Trojan War, that there might have even been a wooden horse, that there was a Helen of Troy. So we teased this at the end of the last episode. Let's get into it. Who is Heinrich Schliemann, probably the most famous archaeologist who ever lived? So Schliemann, he was the son of a Lutheran pastor who got caught up in a sex scandal. And so the young Heinrich was kind of impoverished and humiliated, but discovered that he had an incredible aptitude for languages and ended up a fabulously wealthy businessman. He is a product of Germany at its most expansionist, self-confident, but also kind of insecure. He's a fascinating figure.
特洛伊战争确实发生过，甚至可能真的有木马，也确实有特洛伊的海伦。我们在上一集结尾卖了个关子。现在让我们深入探讨一下。海因里希·施里曼是谁？他可能是史上最著名的考古学家。施里曼是一位路德教牧师的儿子，这位牧师卷入了一场性丑闻。因此，年轻的海因里希生活贫困且备受屈辱，但他发现自己拥有惊人的语言天赋，最终成为了一名极其富有的商人。他是德国处于最扩张、最自信，但也最缺乏安全感时期的产物。他是一个迷人的人物。
And Schliemann would later claim that back when he was a child in Mecklenburg in East Germany, Dominic, he had been reading about Troy and Helen as a seven-year-old. This is probably not true. Schliemann is brilliant at creating his own mythology, ironically enough. He's a kind of great monstrous figure of high achievement, high ambition, kind of almost Wagnerian character. Or maybe even the Kaiser. Oh no, I can't believe you're badmouthing the Kaiser. But he's not always 100% truthful. And Helen is a kind of obsession for him. Just as the Greek heroes go and search for Helen, so does Schliemann. This obsession is so great that in 1869, he's been married to a
多米尼克，施里曼后来声称，当他还是个孩子，住在德国东部的梅克伦堡时，七岁时就读过关于特洛伊和海伦的故事。这很可能不是真的。讽刺的是，施里曼非常擅长创造自己的神话。他是一个成就卓著、野心勃勃的伟大怪物，一个几乎带有瓦格纳色彩的人物。或者甚至像凯撒大帝。噢不，我不敢相信你在诋毁凯撒。但他并不总是百分之百诚实。海伦对他来说是一种执念。正如希腊英雄们去寻找海伦一样，施里曼也是如此。这种执念如此强烈，以至于在 1869 年，他已经与一位
Russian woman. Russian was one of his many languages, and he'd been working in St. Petersburg. He divorces her, and he decides that he'd like a real-life Helen to replace her. Amazingly, he employs a Greek archbishop basically her. And so amazingly, he employs a Greek archbishop basically to pimp him, you know, a suitable Helen. And the archbishop finds one in the form of a 16 year old Greek girl who's called Sophia, who is the Sophia that was name checked in that poem that you read. And Schliemann has specified that she has to be poor and she has to be educated. And so he interviews her and asks her to recite Homer and Sophia does. And so the marriage goes ahead.
俄罗斯女性结婚。俄语是他掌握的多种语言之一，他曾在圣彼得堡工作。他与她离婚，并决定找一个现实生活中的海伦来取代她。令人惊讶的是，他雇佣了一位希腊大主教，基本上是让他……令人惊讶的是，他雇佣了一位希腊大主教，基本上是让他帮忙物色一个合适的海伦。大主教找到了一个 16 岁的希腊女孩，名叫索菲亚，也就是你在那首诗里提到的那个索菲亚。施里曼明确要求她必须贫穷且受过教育。于是他面试了她，让她背诵荷马史诗，索菲亚做到了。于是婚姻就这样成了。
So he has his own Helen in the form of Sophia. The following year in 1870, he goes to the northwestern corner of what is now Turkey, where tradition placed the site of Troy. And he starts excavating a hill called Hisalik. And he's there for two years. And in 1872, he announces that he has found a burnt city, which he identifies with the very Troy burnt by the Greeks. And then the following year in May, he finds a spectacular hoard of gold and silver.
所以他以索菲亚的形式拥有了自己的海伦。次年，即 1870 年，他前往现今土耳其的西北角，传统认为那里是特洛伊的所在地。他开始挖掘一座名为希萨利克（Hisalik）的小山。他在那里待了两年。1872 年，他宣布发现了一座被烧毁的城市，他将其认定为被希腊人烧毁的那个特洛伊。随后在次年五月，他发现了一批壮观的金银宝藏。
And among this hoard, there's a great collection of jewelry, which he calls inevitably the Jewels of Helen. Schliemann tells a story about how Sophia had been with him, how she had carried the jewels from the site where they'd found them in her skirts. This is, again, not true. Sophia had been in Athens at the time. But what Schliemann then does is to dress her up in the jewels and to say that he has found the treasure of Priam, the king of Troy. And it's absolutely brilliant. He seems to have discovered Helen of Troy. Now, Helen, of course, was only one of two sisters who were hatched by Leda, their mother.
在这批宝藏中，有一大批珠宝，他不可避免地将其称为“海伦的珠宝”。施里曼讲述了一个故事，说索菲亚一直和他在一起，说她是如何把在现场发现的珠宝藏在裙子里带出来的。这同样不是真的。当时索菲亚还在雅典。但施里曼随后做的是让她戴上这些珠宝，并声称他发现了特洛伊国王普里阿摩斯的宝藏。这真是太绝了。他似乎真的发现了特洛伊的海伦。当然，海伦只是勒达（Leda）所生的两个姐妹之一。
So we talked about this, Dominic, in the previous episode, how Leda was raped by Zeus in the form of a giant swan and gave birth to Helen, who was Zeus's daughter, and gave birth to Clytemnestra, who was the daughter of Leda's mortal husband, Tyndareus, the king of Sparta. And we talked as well about how Clytemnestra married the elder brother of Menelaus, who was called Agamemnon. And Agamemnon is the king of a Greek city called Mycenae, where Clytemnestra rules as the queen. And so Schliemann, having, in his opinion, discovered Troy, discovered the jewels of Helen, having proven that Helen had actually existed. The obvious target for his next excavation would be Mycenae, the city ruled by Agamemnon, where Helen's sister, Clytemnestra, was queen. So that's what he decides to do. There's a problem with this because Greece is now an independent state, so it's not kind of Lord Elgin conditions
多米尼克，我们在上一集谈到过，勒达是如何被化身为巨大天鹅的宙斯强奸，并生下了宙斯的女儿海伦，以及勒达的凡人丈夫——斯巴达国王廷达柔斯（Tyndareus）的女儿克吕泰涅斯特拉（Clytemnestra）。我们还谈到克吕泰涅斯特拉嫁给了墨涅拉俄斯的哥哥阿伽门农（Agamemnon）。阿伽门农是希腊城市迈锡尼（Mycenae）的国王，克吕泰涅斯特拉在那里担任王后。因此，施里曼在他看来发现了特洛伊，发现了海伦的珠宝，证明了海伦确实存在。他下一次挖掘的明显目标将是迈锡尼，即阿伽门农统治的城市，海伦的姐姐克吕泰涅斯特拉是那里的王后。这就是他决定要做的事。这有个问题，因为希腊现在是一个独立的国家，所以不像埃尔金勋爵（Lord Elgin）那时候的情况，
where he could just turn up and do it. So in 1874, he heads to the Peloponnese, which is the southern bit of Greece. Yeah, the southern peninsula. And he heads to Mycenae, which is kind of in the northeast corner of it, kind of set among mountains. And he starts this completely illegal dig, and the Greeks close it down. So Schliemann gets around this problem by giving a massive bung to the Greek archaeological society, who then decide, yeah, that's great, you can go ahead. And so he starts excavating in this site. And I think there's no question that just as at Troy, he was looking for Helen. So in a sense, at Mycenae, Schliemann is looking for
他不能直接跑过去就开挖。所以 1874 年，他前往伯罗奔尼撒半岛，也就是希腊的南部。是的，南部半岛。他前往位于东北角的迈锡尼，那里坐落在群山之中。他开始了这次完全非法的挖掘，希腊人叫停了它。于是施里曼通过向希腊考古协会行贿一大笔钱解决了这个问题，他们随后决定，好吧，那太棒了，你可以继续。于是他开始在这个遗址进行挖掘。我认为毫无疑问，就像在特洛伊一样，他在寻找海伦。所以从某种意义上说，在迈锡尼，施里曼是在寻找
certainly Agamemnon the king there, but also his wife, Clytemnestra. Because although Clytemnestra is not as celebrated as Helen, she too, like Helen, is a figure of incredible potency in Greek mythology and particularly in tragic literature. Bloodstained figure, Tom. Bloodstained figure, yeah. So although Clytemnestra is not as celebrated as Helen of Troy, I mean, she is a significant figure in Greek mythology and particularly in the literature of democratic Athens in its 5th century BC heyday.
当然是那里的国王阿伽门农，还有他的妻子克吕泰涅斯特拉。因为尽管克吕泰涅斯特拉不像海伦那样出名，但她和海伦一样，在希腊神话中，特别是在悲剧文学中，是一个极具影响力的人物。一个血迹斑斑的人物，汤姆。血迹斑斑的人物，没错。所以尽管克吕泰涅斯特拉不像特洛伊的海伦那样出名，但她是希腊神话中的重要人物，特别是在公元前 5 世纪雅典民主鼎盛时期的文学作品中。
And she is the dominant figure in one of the supreme literary achievements of ancient Athens, which is a series of three plays by a tragedian called Aeschylus. And Aeschylus was a veteran of the Persian Wars. He'd fought at Marathon. He'd fought at Salamis. Every year he would enter a play for the annual contest that the Athenians staged in honor of Dionysus, and he would always win. And eventually he got killed, according to tradition. He was very bald, and an eagle is supposed to have dropped a tortoise on his head, mistaking his head for a stone. Why would that kill you more likely if you were bald
她是古雅典最高文学成就之一的主导人物，即悲剧作家埃斯库罗斯（Aeschylus）创作的三部曲。埃斯库罗斯是波斯战争的老兵。他在马拉松战役中战斗过。他在萨拉米斯战役中战斗过。每年他都会为雅典人纪念狄俄尼索斯而举办的年度竞赛提交一部剧作，而且他总是获胜。根据传统，他最终被杀死了。他非常秃顶，据说一只老鹰把他的头误认为是石头，扔了一只乌龟在上面。为什么秃顶比有头发更容易被砸死？
than if you had a normal head of hair? Because the eagle thought that his bald head was a stone. Oh, okay, fair enough. So, yeah, just tipping you off there to beware of eagles carrying tortoises, Dominic. Yeah. Thank you. And he's commemorated as one of the giant figures of classical Athens and the play that describes Clytemnestra's relationship with Agamemnon in the most detail. And it has to be said, the most bloody detail was called the Agamemnon. And it was part of this trilogy, as I said, that in 458 BC won the top prize. And just as Homer,
因为老鹰以为他秃顶的脑袋是块石头。噢，好吧，有道理。所以，多米尼克，提醒你注意那些带着乌龟的老鹰。是的。谢谢。他被纪念为古典雅典的巨人之一，而最详细地描述克吕泰涅斯特拉与阿伽门农关系的剧作，必须说，也是最血腥的细节，被称为《阿伽门农》。正如我所说，它是那部三部曲的一部分，在公元前 458 年赢得了最高奖项。正如荷马，
when he introduces Helen, takes for granted that people will know who Helen is. So to a degree, Aeschylus is able to take for granted that people will know who Clytemnestra is and who Agamemnon is and what the backdrop to their story is. So I think before we continue with our account of what Schliemann finds in Mycenae, we should perhaps just go into the details of who Clytemnestra is and what the family is that she's married into. Because it has to be said, it is probably the most nightmarish collection of in-laws that anyone could possibly have. So Tom, who are Agamemnon's forebears?
在介绍海伦时，理所当然地认为人们会知道海伦是谁。因此，在某种程度上，埃斯库罗斯也可以理所当然地认为人们会知道克吕泰涅斯特拉是谁，阿伽门农是谁，以及他们故事的背景是什么。所以我认为在我们继续讲述施里曼在迈锡尼的发现之前，我们或许应该深入了解一下克吕泰涅斯特拉是谁，以及她嫁入的那个家族。因为必须说，这可能是任何人所能拥有的最噩梦般的姻亲组合。那么汤姆，阿伽门农的祖先是谁？
So Agamemnon's great-grandfather is a guy called Tantalus, who is the son of Zeus. And he hosts the gods for a great banquet. And basically, just for the bants, he cooks his son, a boy called Pelops, and serves him up in the banquet to see whether the gods will be able to tell his trick. And the gods all do find this, but one of them, Demeter, because she's lost her daughter, Persephone, to the god of the underworld, is very depressed. So she nibbles on the feast and eats Pelops' shoulder. And the gods are incredibly angry. They bring Pelops back to life.
阿伽门农的曾祖父是一个叫坦塔洛斯（Tantalus）的人，他是宙斯的儿子。他为众神举办了一场盛大的宴会。基本上，只是为了恶作剧，他煮了自己的儿子，一个叫珀罗普斯（Pelops）的男孩，并把他端上宴席，看看众神是否能识破他的诡计。众神都发现了，但其中一位，德墨忒尔（Demeter），因为失去了女儿珀耳塞福涅（Persephone）给冥王，非常沮丧。所以她啃了宴席上的食物，吃掉了珀罗普斯的肩膀。众神非常愤怒。他们让珀罗普斯复活了。
They give him a shoulder made of ivory and they put Tantalus in the depths of hell. Right. Yeah. Where he's surrounded by water, which he can't drink and by grapes, which are always out of reach. He's being tantalized, Tom. Yeah. So he's tantalized.
他们给了他一个象牙做的肩膀，并把坦塔洛斯关进了地狱深处。没错。是的。在那里，他被水包围却喝不到，被葡萄包围却够不着。他正在受折磨（tantalized），汤姆。是的。所以他被折磨了。
Pelops, his son, we've actually already mentioned him. He's the guy who founds the Olympic Games and he gives his name to the Peloponnese, the island of Pelops. And he has won the daughter of the King of Olympia by cheating. He's entered a chariot race with this king and the king's charioteer has been bribed by Pelops to replace the axle with wax so that the wheels go bouncing off. The king gets killed. And after the race, the charioteer approaches Pelops for his reward and Pelops tells him basically to bog off. So the charioteer curses Pelops. So that's two layers of curses. We've got Tartarus and we've got Pelops. Pelops has various children, two of whom are called Atreus and Paestes. And Atreus and Thaestes kill one of
他的儿子珀罗普斯，我们其实已经提到过他了。他是创立奥林匹克运动会的人，并以他的名字命名了伯罗奔尼撒半岛，即珀罗普斯之岛。他通过作弊赢得了奥林匹亚国王的女儿。他与这位国王进行了一场战车比赛，国王的战车夫被珀罗普斯收买，用蜡代替了车轴，导致轮子飞了出去。国王被杀。比赛结束后，战车夫向珀罗普斯索要报酬，珀罗普斯基本上让他滚蛋。于是战车夫诅咒了珀罗普斯。所以这是两层诅咒。我们有塔尔塔罗斯（地狱），还有珀罗普斯。珀罗普斯有几个孩子，其中两个叫阿特柔斯（Atreus）和提厄斯忒斯（Thyestes）。阿特柔斯和提厄斯忒斯杀死了
their half-brothers because they want him out of the way. And Pelops is furious about this, as he would be, and exiles them. And they go off to Mycenae, conquer it, and they both rule it. But Atreus wants Thaestes out of the way. And so following in the footsteps of his grandfather, he takes Thaestes' children, cooks them, puts them in a dish and gives them to Thaestes for dinner. And Thaestes, because he's not a god, doesn't realize what he's being served. So he goes ahead and eats them. And after he's eaten them, Atreus brandishes their heads and hands and feet, has a good laugh about it. And of course, Thaisnes is, to add insult to injury, not only has he eaten his own children, but he has to go into exile because he's guilty of cannibalism.
他们同父异母的兄弟，因为他们想除掉他。珀罗普斯对此非常愤怒，理所当然，并将他们流放了。他们去了迈锡尼，征服了它，并共同统治。但阿特柔斯想除掉提厄斯忒斯。于是，追随他祖父的脚步，他抓住了提厄斯忒斯的儿子们，煮了他们，放在盘子里端给提厄斯忒斯吃。提厄斯忒斯因为不是神，没有意识到他吃的是什么。所以他吃掉了他们。吃完后，阿特柔斯挥舞着他们的头颅、手和脚，对此大笑不已。当然，提厄斯忒斯不仅吃了自己的孩子，还因为犯下食人罪而不得不流亡，真是雪上加霜。
Yeah. He's the real victim in all this. Very sad. Yeah. I mean, completely. So he's obviously very cross about this. So he goes to Delphi, the Oracle of Apollo, and Apollo offers him some terrible advice. So he's obviously very cross about this. So he goes to Delphi, the Oracle of Apollo, and Apollo offers him some terrible advice. So Apollo says that what he should do to get back at Atreus is to disguise himself and to rape his own daughter. His own daughter? His own daughter.
是的。他是这一切中真正的受害者。真可怜。是的。我的意思是，完全是。所以他显然对此非常生气。于是他去了德尔斐，阿波罗的神谕所，阿波罗给了他一些糟糕的建议。所以他显然对此非常生气。于是他去了德尔斐，阿波罗的神谕所，阿波罗给了他一些糟糕的建议。阿波罗说，他要报复阿特柔斯，就应该伪装自己并强奸自己的女儿。他自己的女儿？他自己的女儿。
So he does this. The daughter doesn't realise who the rapist is. What? She doesn't recognise her own father? Because he's disgu's disguised that's the point a hell of a disguise anyway continue she gives birth to a son who she calls a gistus and she's so traumatized by the fact that this boy is the son of rape that she exposes him on the mountainside where as always happens in these stories, he gets rescued by shepherds. Always the way. And by a long process of improbable coincidences, he ends up as the foster brother of Agamemnon and Menelaus in Mycenae because they are the sons of Atreus. So there is Atreus. He's got his two sons,
于是他照做了。女儿没有意识到强奸犯是谁。什么？她认不出自己的父亲？因为他伪装了，这就是重点，无论如何，这伪装太离谱了，继续。她生下了一个儿子，取名为埃癸斯托斯（Aegisthus）。她因为这个男孩是强奸的产物而受到极大的创伤，于是把他遗弃在山坡上，正如这些故事中常发生的那样，他被牧羊人救了。总是这样。经过一连串不可思议的巧合，他最终成为了阿伽门农和墨涅拉俄斯在迈锡尼的寄养兄弟，因为他们是阿特柔斯的儿子。所以阿特柔斯就在那里。他有两个儿子，
Agamemnon and Menelaus, and he's got Aegisthus, who is the son of the brother who he has treated so appallingly in due course a gist this discovers his true paternity and kills atreus and he drives agamemnon and menelaus out of mycenae and they go to sparta and this is when menelaus manages to to win helen so i said in the first episode Menelaus doesn't have a palace to take Helen to. This is why. Because he's an exile. He's an exile. And this is also when Agamemnon marries Clytemnestra. So you have these two brothers who are married to the two sisters. It's going to be a quiz at the end of this episode. Agamemnon and Menelaus then lead an army, kick Agisthus out of Mycenae, and they seize control of it.
阿伽门农和墨涅拉俄斯，还有一个埃癸斯托斯，他是那个被他残酷对待的兄弟的儿子。后来，埃癸斯托斯发现了自己的真实身世，杀死了阿特柔斯，并将阿伽门农和墨涅拉俄斯赶出了迈锡尼。他们去了斯巴达，这就是墨涅拉俄斯设法赢得海伦的时候。所以我在第一集里说过，墨涅拉俄斯没有宫殿可以带海伦去。这就是原因。因为他是流亡者。他是流亡者。这也是阿伽门农娶克吕泰涅斯特拉的时候。所以你有这两个兄弟，分别娶了两个姐妹。这集结束时会有个测验。阿伽门农和墨涅拉俄斯随后率领军队，将埃癸斯托斯赶出迈锡尼，并夺取了控制权。
And that is the state of play when Helen is abducted by Paris. So they're back in situ. They are back in Mycenae. They're back in situ. I mean, it's complicated. Greek murderous stories of cannibalism and incest always are. But basically there's been a lot of very, very bad behaviour. And it means that Agamemnon and
这就是海伦被帕里斯（Paris）绑架时的局势。所以他们回到了原位。他们回到了迈锡尼。他们回到了原位。我的意思是，这很复杂。希腊关于食人和乱伦的谋杀故事总是这样。但基本上发生了很多非常、非常糟糕的行为。这意味着阿伽门农和
Menelaus have inherited three generations worth of monstrous behavior by their forebears. And so they are operating under a terrible curse. And particularly Agamemnon is, because he is now, with the death of Atreus, the head of the family. He is the king of Mycenae. Now, as king of Mycenae, he proves a brilliant king. He establishes Mycenae as the most powerful state in the whole of Greece. He is described by Homer as Anax Andron, lord of men, wide ruling. This is great for Clytemnestra. She's queen of the most powerful man in Greece. And they have various children, of whom the eldest is a daughter called Iphigenia. Then they have another daughter called Electra. And they have a son called Orestes.
墨涅拉俄斯继承了他们祖先三代人的可怕行为。所以他们正处于一个可怕的诅咒之下。尤其是阿伽门农，因为随着阿特柔斯的去世，他现在是家族的首领。他是迈锡尼的国王。作为迈锡尼的国王，他证明了自己是一位出色的国王。他被荷马描述为“Anax Andron”，即“人中之王，广阔统治者”。这对克吕泰涅斯特拉来说太棒了。她是希腊最有权势男人的王后。他们有几个孩子，其中长女叫伊菲革涅亚（Iphigenia）。然后他们还有另一个女儿叫厄勒克特拉（Electra）。他们还有一个儿子叫俄瑞斯忒斯（Orestes）。
Then the abduction of Helen happens. And Agamemnon, like all the other Greeks, is obliged to help Menelaus get Helen back. And all the Greek forces gather at a place called Aulis, which is kind of north of where Athens is on the coast. And Agamemnon goes out hunting and he's hunting this deer. And the deer takes refuge in a grove that is sacred to Artemis, the goddess of the hunt. And Agamemnon goes in and he kills the deer. And Artemis is furious about this. She sends bad winds, doesn't she so the fleet
然后海伦被绑架了。阿伽门农像所有其他希腊人一样，有义务帮助墨涅拉俄斯夺回海伦。所有的希腊军队聚集在一个叫奥利斯（Aulis）的地方，它位于雅典海岸的北面。阿伽门农出去打猎，他正在猎杀一只鹿。这只鹿躲进了一个神圣的树林里，那是狩猎女神阿耳忒弥斯（Artemis）的圣地。阿伽门农进去杀死了那只鹿。阿耳忒弥斯对此非常愤怒。她送来了恶风，不是吗？所以舰队
can't leave exactly yeah and the greek fleet is stuck in aulis and having been to aulis there's a massive cement works there so it's not a place that you would want to be stuck at all agamemnon is told by the soothsayer who is accompanying the greeks that you know there'll be so many children killed in this story he's told the only way that the winds will change is if you sacrifice your own daughter, Iphigenia, to Artemis. And Agamemnon knows Clytemnestra will not allow this to happen. You know, she's devoted to her daughters. And Agamemnon tricks Clytemnestra by saying, we're going to marry Iphigenia to Achilles, the greatest of the Greek warriors. And Clytemnestra
无法离开，没错。希腊舰队被困在奥利斯。我去过奥利斯，那里有一个巨大的水泥厂，所以那根本不是你想被困住的地方。阿伽门农被随行的占卜师告知，你知道，在这个故事中会有很多孩子被杀，他被告知改变风向的唯一方法就是将你自己的女儿伊菲革涅亚献祭给阿耳忒弥斯。阿伽门农知道克吕泰涅斯特拉不会允许这种情况发生。你知道，她对女儿们非常疼爱。阿伽门农欺骗了克吕泰涅斯特拉，说我们要把伊菲革涅亚嫁给希腊最伟大的战士阿喀琉斯（Achilles）。克吕泰涅斯特拉
and Iphigenia are thrilled about this. And so Clytemnestra brings Iphigenia to Aulis. And when she arrives there, Iphigenia is seized and she is sacrificed. And the winds promptly change and Agamemnon and all the Greeks are able to sail off to Troy and Clytemnestra is left completely distraught and not just distraught, but set on revenge. And so while Agamemnon is in Greece, she decides that she will shack up with the one man who is pledged to eternal enmity to Agamemnon, which is Aegisthus. Yes. So that's for those people who haven't been making notes, so Aegisthus is Agamemnon's
和伊菲革涅亚对此感到非常兴奋。于是克吕泰涅斯特拉把伊菲革涅亚带到了奥利斯。当她到达那里时，伊菲革涅亚被抓走并被献祭了。风立刻改变了，阿伽门农和所有的希腊人得以航行前往特洛伊，而克吕泰涅斯特拉则完全崩溃了，不仅是崩溃，而且一心想要报复。所以当阿伽门农在希腊时，她决定与那个发誓与阿伽门农永世为敌的人住在一起，那就是埃癸斯托斯。是的。所以对于那些没有做笔记的人，埃癸斯托斯是阿伽门农的
cousin, who was himself the son of his grandfather, is also his father. That's right, isn't it? Yeah. Who slept with his own daughter. And he is now shacked up with Clytemnestra. In Mycenae. In Mycenae. And she has just seen her own daughter sacrificed by her husband,
堂兄弟，他本人是他祖父的儿子，也是他的父亲。没错，是这样吧？是的。那个和自己女儿睡觉的人。他现在和克吕泰涅斯特拉住在一起。在迈锡尼。在迈锡尼。而她刚刚目睹了自己的女儿被丈夫献祭，
who is this bloke's cousin. In due course, what happens is that Troy falls and watchtowers are lit and the blaze of the watchtowers are seen in Mycenae. And Clytemnestra knows therefore that Agamemnon is coming back. So this is where Aeschylus' great play begins, the blaze of the watchtowers, the news Troy has fallen. And to begin with, it seems as though Clytemnestra is overjoyed by this. She says, wonderful, my husband is coming back. Can't wait. Agamemnon comes back. He's driving a chariot. Behind him is a daughter of the king of Priam called Cassandra, who had been much loved by Apollo. Apollo had given her the gift of prophecy, but Cassandra had then turned Apollo down. Apollo had cursed her by saying that although
而那个丈夫是这家伙的堂兄弟。后来，特洛伊陷落了，瞭望塔被点亮，瞭望塔的火光在迈锡尼被看到。因此克吕泰涅斯特拉知道阿伽门农要回来了。这就是埃斯库罗斯伟大剧作开始的地方，瞭望塔的火光，特洛伊陷落的消息。起初，克吕泰涅斯特拉似乎为此欣喜若狂。她说，太棒了，我丈夫要回来了。等不及了。阿伽门农回来了。他开着战车。在他身后是普里阿摩斯国王的女儿卡珊德拉（Cassandra），她曾深受阿波罗的喜爱。阿波罗给了她预言的天赋，但卡珊德拉随后拒绝了阿波罗。阿波罗诅咒她，说虽然
she had the ability to see the future, no one would ever believe her. Agamemnon has seized her and made her his concubine. Agamemnon really is asking for trouble. He's killed his own daughter, he's deceived his wife, and he's now returned with a slave girl in tow. But Clytemnestra pretends to be absolutely thrilled. She says, I've been tending the home fires, I've been completely faithful. Lovely to have you back. Absolutely brilliant. And look, I have all these wonderful purple robes. Why don't you enter the palace stepping onto these robes? And Agamemnon is nervous because he knows that this is the kind of thing that might anger the gods. And so he's reluctant, but Clytemnestra urges him and urges him. And finally he says, okay, I will. And so he steps onto the robes and goes inside. But before he's gone inside, he asks that Cassandra be well looked
她有预见未来的能力，但没有人会相信她。阿伽门农抓住了她，让她做了自己的妾。阿伽门农真的是在自找麻烦。他杀了自己的女儿，欺骗了妻子，现在又带着一个奴隶女孩回来了。但克吕泰涅斯特拉假装非常兴奋。她说，我一直在操持家务，我一直非常忠诚。很高兴你回来。太棒了。看，我有这些漂亮的紫色长袍。你为什么不踩着这些长袍进入宫殿呢？阿伽门农很紧张，因为他知道这可能会激怒众神。所以他很勉强，但克吕泰涅斯特拉不断催促他。最后他说，好吧，我会的。于是他踩上长袍走了进去。但在进去之前，他要求卡珊德拉得到妥善照顾。
after. And so Cassandra addresses the chorus, addresses the watching people. And because she has the powers of prophecy, she knows what is going to happen so she says oh my god agamemnon is going to be killed and then she too vanishes into the palace and in iskallus's play you hear kind of screams agamemnon crying out and then cliton nestra comes out covered in blood yes this is my work and i claim it to prevent flight or resistance foiling death, I cast on him as one who catches fish a vast voluminous net that walled him round with endless wealth of woven folds. And then I struck him twice. Twice he cried out and groaned and then fell limp. And as he lay, I gave a third and final blow, my thanks for prayers fulfilled to Zeus. So falling, he belched
于是卡珊德拉向合唱队讲话，向围观的人讲话。因为她有预言的能力，她知道将会发生什么，所以她说，噢天哪，阿伽门农要被杀了。然后她也消失在宫殿里。在埃斯库罗斯的剧中，你听到了一种尖叫声，阿伽门农的呼喊，然后克吕泰涅斯特拉满身是血地走出来。是的，这是我的杰作，我声称这是为了防止逃跑或抵抗破坏死亡，我像捕鱼一样向他投下了一张巨大而宽大的网，用无穷无尽的编织褶皱将他围住。然后我击中了他两次。他尖叫并呻吟了两次，然后瘫倒在地。当他躺在那里时，我给了他第三次也是最后一次打击，感谢宙斯实现了我的祈祷。所以他倒下时，呕吐出
forth his life with cough and wretch there spurted from him bloody foam in a fierce jet and spreading spattered me with drops of crimson rain just for good measure cassandra too has been murdered and then who should come out of the palace but agisthus so he's been there the whole time he's been hanging out the whole time yeah claims it was his plan, celebrates his vengeance. And he and Clytemnestra say, brilliant, we're now going to rule in Agamemnon's place. And Clytemnestra says, this was vengeance for the murder of Iphigenia. So brilliant.
了他的生命，伴随着咳嗽和干呕，鲜血从他身上喷涌而出，形成一股猛烈的喷流，溅了我一身深红色的雨。为了保险起见，卡珊德拉也被谋杀了。然后谁从宫殿里走出来？是埃癸斯托斯。所以他一直都在那里，他一直都在那里闲逛。是的，声称这是他的计划，庆祝他的复仇。他和克吕泰涅斯特拉说，太棒了，我们现在要取代阿伽门农统治。克吕泰涅斯特拉说，这是为谋杀伊菲革涅亚的复仇。太棒了。
And that is where the play ends. Yeah. But of course, that's just the beginning of this huge cycle of vengeance, which people who are familiar with Greek tragedy will know, because their children, their surviving children, decide that they are going to get revenge on their own mother. It's nice, isn't it? I mean, it's a terrible situation to be in, isn't it? You know, your mother's killed your father.
这就是剧作结束的地方。是的。但当然，这只是这场巨大复仇循环的开始，熟悉希腊悲剧的人会知道，因为他们的孩子，幸存的孩子，决定要向自己的母亲复仇。这很好，不是吗？我的意思是，这是一种可怕的处境，不是吗？你知道，你母亲杀了你父亲。
And not only that, but you have Apollo, the god of prophecy, who is not a god you want to ignore, basically telling you to go and kill your mother. So this is the second play, the Libation Bearers, it's called. Orestes, the son of Agamemnon and Clytemnestra, has gone to Delphi, and Apollo has basically said, you have to go and kill your mother. And so he does that. He kills Aegisthus and he kills Clytemnestra. But to kill your mother is the worst of crimes. And there are very, very ancient divinities, older than the gods on Olympus, who lurk in the depths of the earth, whose role it is to punish those who break the natural order. And there is no greater crime against the natural order than to kill your own mother. And so the moment Orestes has killed Clytemnestra, these terrible monsters appear and they're called Furies. They have
不仅如此，你还有预言之神阿波罗，他不是你想忽视的神，基本上告诉你去杀了你的母亲。所以这是第二部剧，叫《奠酒人》（The Libation Bearers）。阿伽门农和克吕泰涅斯特拉的儿子俄瑞斯忒斯去了德尔斐，阿波罗基本上说，你必须去杀了你的母亲。于是他照做了。他杀了埃癸斯托斯，杀了克吕泰涅斯特拉。但杀害母亲是最大的罪行。有一些非常、非常古老的神灵，比奥林匹斯山上的神更古老，潜伏在地底深处，他们的职责是惩罚那些破坏自然秩序的人。没有比杀害自己的母亲更大的罪行了。所以当俄瑞斯忒斯杀死克吕泰涅斯特拉的那一刻，这些可怕的怪物出现了，她们被称为复仇女神（Furies）。她们有
snakes for hair. They carry whips. They're kind of monstrous and loathsome in appearance. And Orestes has no choice but to flee them. And so this seems to be his fate, that for the rest of his existence, he will be pursued by these Furies with their whips. And this is what is happening in the third play, the Eumenides, which in Greek means the kindly ones. It opens with Orestes, he's snatched a brief moment to consult Apollo again, because Apollo has put the Furies to sleep. And this gives him the chance to kind of give them the slip and Orestes heads for Athens. The Furies are snoring and the ghost of Clytemnestra appears. So Clytemnestra is the only figure who appears in all three of these plays. The Furies head off to Athens to get Orestes. That's their job. And they corner Orestes there.
蛇一样的头发。她们带着鞭子。她们看起来既可怕又令人厌恶。俄瑞斯忒斯别无选择，只能逃离她们。这似乎成了他的命运，在余生中，他将被这些带着鞭子的复仇女神追赶。这就是第三部剧《复仇女神》（The Eumenides）中发生的事情，在希腊语中意为“仁慈者”。剧作以俄瑞斯忒斯开始，他抓住了短暂的机会再次咨询阿波罗，因为阿波罗让复仇女神睡着了。这让他有机会溜走，俄瑞斯忒斯前往雅典。复仇女神在打呼噜，克吕泰涅斯特拉的鬼魂出现了。所以克吕泰涅斯特拉是唯一出现在这三部剧中的人物。复仇女神前往雅典去抓俄瑞斯忒斯。那是她们的工作。她们在那里把俄瑞斯忒斯逼到了绝境。
And Orestes begs Athena for help. And Athena appears. And she introduces something very novel and radical, something that Greece and the world, till that moment, had not seen, which is a courtroom. Right. So it's the world's first courtroom trial. Yeah. So Athena says, this is what we're going to do. We'll get a jury. We'll get various mortals who will decide whether Orestes should be let off or not. The Furies don't like it, but they accept it. They can't argue with Athena. And at the end of the trial, the jury is hung. And so the casting vote is with Athena. And she says, I'm going to let him off. And the Furies are absolutely indignant.
俄瑞斯忒斯恳求雅典娜（Athena）帮助。雅典娜出现了。她引入了一些非常新颖和激进的东西，希腊乃至世界在那一刻之前从未见过，那就是法庭。没错。所以这是世界上第一次法庭审判。是的。雅典娜说，我们要这样做。我们会找一个陪审团。我们会找一些凡人来决定俄瑞斯忒斯是否应该被释放。复仇女神不喜欢这样，但她们接受了。她们无法与雅典娜争辩。审判结束时，陪审团陷入僵局。所以决定性的投票权在雅典娜手中。她说，我要放了他。复仇女神感到非常愤怒。
But Athena says, you've got to accept it, that we're going to have this new legal order. We can't have people committing crimes and then being chased by monsters with whips. This is no basis for a stable civic society. So from this point on on we're going to have law courts and all this kind of thing but you can be the guardians of it and by doing that you will be showing how kind you are which is why henceforward you will no longer be called the furies but the humanities the kindly ones so that's where the name of the play comes from yeah and it's a kind of brilliant maneuver by aeschylus because basically he's saying that these ancient
但雅典娜说，你必须接受这一点，我们将建立这种新的法律秩序。我们不能让人犯罪，然后被带着鞭子的怪物追赶。这不是一个稳定的公民社会的基础。所以从现在开始，我们将有法庭等等，但你们可以成为它的守护者，通过这样做，你们将展示你们是多么仁慈，这就是为什么从今以后，你们将不再被称为复仇女神，而是被称为“仁慈者”（Eumenides），这就是剧名的由来。是的，这是埃斯库罗斯的一种绝妙策略，因为他基本上是在说，这些古老的
epic cycles of bloodshed and revenge, which have been rippling through generation after generation after generation, it is stopped and eased, not just in Athens, but in an Athens that has the institutions of democratic government. So the story symbolizes the transition from a world of blood feuds and vengeance passed down the generations to one in which a law court, so in this case it's the Areopagus, isn't it? The sort of elite. The hill of Ares, yeah. The elders of Athens, so they are judging cases. So that's what the story is dramatizing, is that right?
代代相传的血腥和复仇的史诗循环，它被停止和缓解了，不仅是在雅典，而且是在一个拥有民主政府制度的雅典。所以这个故事象征着从血仇和代代相传的复仇世界，向一个拥有法庭的世界的转变，所以在这个案例中是战神山议会（Areopagus），对吧？精英阶层。阿瑞斯之山，没错。雅典的长老们，所以他们在审判案件。所以这就是故事所戏剧化的内容，对吗？
I think it is dramatizing an idea that the old world of kind of epic violence has faded and been succeeded by a better order. But it's obviously specifically making Athens and its democracy look good. Specifically, there've been all these kind of convulsions in Athens, the frameworks of democracy in the process of being set up and revised. And Aeschylus is basically saying that this quite novel legal framework, rather than just having been invented recently, actually reaches back to the legendary age of Agamemnon and so on. And so Aeschylus himself said that his plays were slices cut from the great feast of Homer. And it's a perfect example of how these figures like Helen, like Clytemnestra, can be used by writers to channel understandings of revolutionary processes within Greek society and to tame it.
我认为它戏剧化了一个观念，即那种史诗暴力的旧世界已经消逝，并被一种更好的秩序所取代。但它显然是在特别让雅典及其民主看起来很好。特别是，雅典经历了各种动荡，民主的框架正在建立和修订中。埃斯库罗斯基本上是在说，这种相当新颖的法律框架，与其说是最近才发明的，不如说实际上可以追溯到阿伽门农等人的传奇时代。所以埃斯库罗斯本人说，他的剧作是从荷马的盛宴中切下的薄片。这是一个完美的例子，说明像海伦、克吕泰涅斯特拉这样的人物，如何被作家用来引导对希腊社会内部革命进程的理解，并驯服它。
It opens up the obvious question which really Schliemann is trying to answer which is that is that what homer did so just as iscales is using homer and adapting it was homer doing the same was he taking much older stories and adapting them and if he was doing that then is it possible that cliton estra and helen were actual real people yeah and schiemann, to his own satisfaction, has proved that Helen was a real person. But now that he's arrived at Mycenae and he's had permission from the Greek government to excavate there, his goal is to try and see whether Clytemnestra and Agamemnon are also real. And that's his goal. Let's find that out after the break and find out at last the history behind the mystery. of espresso drinks does Julia like anyway? Is it too late to change your latte order? But with an espresso machine by KitchenAid, you wouldn't be thinking any of this, because you could have just made your espresso at home. Shop now at KitchenAid.ca.
这引出了一个显而易见的问题，施里曼确实试图回答这个问题，那就是荷马也是这样做的吗？正如埃斯库罗斯使用荷马并改编它一样，荷马也在做同样的事情吗？他是在采用更古老的故事并改编它们吗？如果他这样做，那么克吕泰涅斯特拉和海伦是否可能是真实存在的人？是的，施里曼对他自己的满足感来说，已经证明了海伦是一个真实的人。但现在他已经到达迈锡尼，并获得了希腊政府的挖掘许可，他的目标是尝试看看克吕泰涅斯特拉和阿伽门农是否也是真实的。这就是他的目标。让我们在休息后找出答案，并最终找出谜团背后的历史。朱莉娅到底喜欢喝什么样的浓缩咖啡？现在改拿铁订单还来得及吗？但如果有一台 KitchenAid 浓缩咖啡机，你就不会有这些顾虑了，因为你完全可以在家自制浓缩咖啡。立即前往 KitchenAid.ca 选购。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com.
我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的余味》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一点演艺圈八卦的地方，在我们的问答环节，我们会揭开娱乐界的幕布，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场演出门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。
That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The rest is history this corpse very much resembles the image which my imagination formed long ago of wide ruling agamemnon so you may remember that at the beginning of the episode we talked about how heinrich schlieman having been to Troy, has got permission to excavate at Mycenae. And this is the telegram that he sent in 1876 to a Greek newspaper once he'd got to Mycenae and got to work. And this was later abbreviated, it was kind of condensed to the sentence, I have gazed upon the face of Agamemnon. And if you're at all familiar with ancient Greece and with archaeology and stuff, you will no doubt have seen that image of the gold mask, which is now, if you Google Agamemnon, the gold mask is what comes up. And that is generally taken as Agamemnon's mask, even though there's no evidence, of course, that it was. Or was it, Tom?
那是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余味》。这具尸体非常像我很久以前想象中广阔统治者阿伽门农的形象。所以你可能还记得，在这一集开头，我们谈到了海因里希·施里曼在去过特洛伊之后，获得了在迈锡尼挖掘的许可。这是他在 1876 年到达迈锡尼并开始工作后发给一家希腊报纸的电报。这后来被缩写，被浓缩为一句话：“我凝视了阿伽门农的面容。”如果你对古希腊和考古学等有所了解，你无疑会看到那张金面具的图像，现在如果你谷歌搜索“阿伽门农”，出来的就是那张金面具。这通常被认为是阿伽门农的面具，尽管当然没有证据表明它是。或者它是吗，汤姆？
So there's a difference between Mycenae and Troy. Troy had been forgotten about. Nobody knew where it was. People always knew where Mycenae was. And people had already begun excavating there. So as early as 1700, a Venetian engineer had gone and he had removed all the kind of debris that had slid down the mountain and buried Mycenae.
迈锡尼和特洛伊之间是有区别的。特洛伊已经被遗忘了。没人知道它在哪里。人们一直都知道迈锡尼在哪里。而且人们已经开始在那里挖掘了。早在 1700 年，一位威尼斯工程师就去过那里，他移除了所有从山上滑落并掩埋了迈锡尼的碎片。
And actually, Lord Elgin had gone there. So the gateway into Mycenae. And actually Lord Elgin had gone there. So the gateway into Mycenae, it's called the Lion Gate. It has two images of lions over it, although actually they're not lions, they're lionesses, which is appropriate bearing in mind that it was the home of Clive of Nestor. And he wanted to take that back to the British Museum as well, but he couldn't because it is enormous. Mycenae is built out of the most enormous stones. And so even the Greeks were impressed. They called it Cyclopean. Cyclops is a kind of giant one-eyed monsters who were supposed to have built it. So it's not as though Schliemann is dealing archaeologically with entirely virgin territory when he starts digging
实际上埃尔金勋爵也去过那里。所以迈锡尼的入口，它被称为狮子门。上面有两个狮子的图像，尽管实际上它们不是狮子，而是母狮，考虑到它是克吕泰涅斯特拉的家，这很合适。他也想把那个带回大英博物馆，但他做不到，因为它太巨大了。迈锡尼是用最巨大的石头建造的。所以连希腊人都印象深刻。他们称之为“独眼巨人式”（Cyclopean）。独眼巨人是一种巨大的单眼怪物，据说就是他们建造了它。所以当施里曼在 1876 年开始挖掘时，他并不是在处理完全未开发的考古处女地，
there in 1876, but he does have a nose for the incredible find. And what he's done is that kind of just to the right of the Lion Gate, inside the great walls of Mycenae, he's found a circle of stone slabs. And within it, there's a kind of series of weird, upright stones. And some of these have relief sculptures. And Schliemann, the moment he finds these, he says, brilliant, I found the tombs of Agamemnon and Cassandra. So he's immediately identifying his archaeological finds with the stories that he's read in Aeschylus and so on. But even better, he finds these very, very kind of deep shaft graves beneath the tombstones. And he excavates these. And in each of these tombs, he finds bodies. Sometimes he finds treasure. He finds all kinds of stuff. And in each of these tombs, he finds bodies. Sometimes he finds treasure. He finds
但他确实有一种发现惊人发现的嗅觉。他所做的是，就在狮子门右侧，迈锡尼大墙内，他发现了一个石板圈。在里面，有一系列奇怪的直立石头。其中一些有浮雕。施里曼一发现这些，就说，太棒了，我发现了阿伽门农和卡珊德拉的坟墓。所以他立即将他的考古发现与他在埃斯库罗斯等人作品中读到的故事联系起来。但更好的是，他在墓碑下发现了非常、非常深的竖井墓。他挖掘了这些。在每一个坟墓里，他都发现了尸体。有时他发现了宝藏。他发现了各种各样的东西。在每一个坟墓里，他都发现了尸体。有时他发现了宝藏。他发现了
all kinds of stuff. And some of the bodies are wearing masks. And it's in the final shaft that he finds the famous mask, the one of gold, which is always called the face of Agamemnon. But the thing is that this isn't actually what Schliemann meant by the face of Agamemnon. When he lifted the mask, the face beneath it crumbled. So he never actually, you know, he didn't know what that face looked like, but there was another one in another tomb. So when he was talking about the face of Agamemnon, what he actually was referring to was not the mask, but to a head that had survived, a kind of skull that had survived. And he did a drawing of it, and it appeared in the book that he published about his excavations at Mycenae. And it looks like E.T. That's 3000 years old, right? Or whatever, however many thousand years
各种各样的东西。有些尸体戴着面具。在最后一个竖井里，他发现了著名的面具，那个金色的，总是被称为“阿伽门农的面容”。但问题是，这实际上并不是施里曼所说的“阿伽门农的面容”。当他揭开面具时，下面的脸碎了。所以他实际上从来没有，你知道，他不知道那张脸长什么样，但在另一个坟墓里还有一张。所以当他谈到阿伽门农的面容时，他实际上指的不是面具，而是一个幸存下来的头颅，一种幸存下来的头骨。他画了一张草图，它出现在他出版的关于迈锡尼挖掘的书里。它看起来像 E.T.。那有 3000 年历史了，对吧？或者无论多少千年。
old. How old is it? Well, it's actually older than Schliemann thought because Schliemann thought that it was dated to around 1250 BC, which is the date of the Trojan war, but it's actually about 400 years older than that. So even if Agamemnon had existed, it wasn't Agamemnon. And this gets discovered in the wake of Schliemann's finds, because basically in the wake of Schliemann, archaeology begins to kind of professionalize itself. And over the course of the 20th century, kind of academic archaeologists come to feel really embarrassed about the idea that you're going to these places to look for legendary figures. It's a bit like archaeologists going to Palestine start to feel a bit embarrassed about the idea that they're looking for biblical sites. Or if you ask an archaeologist about King Arthur, they sigh and they look very miserable because you're trying to make it too interesting.
旧。它有多旧？实际上它比施里曼认为的还要古老，因为施里曼认为它大约可以追溯到公元前1250年，也就是特洛伊战争的时期，但它实际上比那还要早大约400年。所以即使阿伽门农真的存在，那也不是阿伽门农。这在施里曼的发现之后被揭示出来，因为基本上在施里曼之后，考古学开始变得专业化。在20世纪的过程中，学术界的考古学家们开始对那种为了寻找传说人物而去这些地方的想法感到非常尴尬。这有点像去巴勒斯坦的考古学家开始对寻找圣经遗址的想法感到尴尬一样。或者如果你问一位考古学家关于亚瑟王的事，他们会叹气，看起来非常痛苦，因为你试图让它变得太有趣了。
You're having too much fun and they want to suck the life out of it. But also, of course, in the wake of the Second World War, there were further reasons, which is that, you know, the emphasis on Helen being white and golden haired and Agamemnon as a great ruler of men, this had been very strongly eulogized by Nazis, among others. Of course, I forgot. The Nazis thought that the ancient Greeksreeks were um good arians didn't they yeah so there was a definite sense that kind of looking for these legendary figures
你玩得太开心了，而他们想把其中的乐趣抽干。当然，在第二次世界大战之后，还有其他原因，那就是，你知道，对海伦是金发碧眼的白人女性以及阿伽门农是伟大的人类统治者的强调，这曾被纳粹等人强烈地赞美过。当然，我忘了。纳粹认为古希腊人是优秀的雅利安人，不是吗？是的，所以有一种明确的感觉，即寻找这些希腊神话中的传说人物
of greek myth was kind of incipiently nazi and also the other thing that happens is that the language used by the mycenaeans what's called linear b gets cracked and people can start reading what is on all the kind of burnt tablets that have been found at various cities like Mycenae across Greece. And it opens up a world not of Homeric warriors, but of bureaucrats. And you get records of kind of farmers and potters and weavers and so on yeah and there's nothing about golden haired warriors chariots or anything like that yeah and this contributes to a sense after the second world war that it's somehow politically the wrong thing to do not just to emphasize on homeric warriors but on the very idea of warriors that's exactly as it is with the Vikings, right?
在某种程度上是纳粹主义的萌芽。此外，另一件事是迈锡尼人使用的语言，即所谓的线性文字B被破译了，人们可以开始阅读在希腊各地如迈锡尼等城市发现的各种烧毁的泥板上的内容。它开启的不是荷马笔下的战士世界，而是一个官僚的世界。你会看到关于农民、陶工、织工等的记录，是的，没有任何关于金发战士、战车之类的东西，是的。这导致二战后人们产生了一种感觉，即不仅强调荷马式的战士，甚至强调战士这一概念本身，在政治上都是错误的。这和维京人的情况完全一样，对吧？
It's all about multicultural trading links and, you know, rethinking gender roles. Exactly. And celebrating migration. And actually, what everybody's itching to say is, what about the stuff about smashing people's heads in with axes? Where's all that? That's the fun stuff. Well, I mean, most obviously, the fact that you've got these enormous fortifications built
这完全是关于多元文化的贸易联系，你知道，重新思考性别角色。没错。而且是在庆祝移民。实际上，每个人都急于说的是，那些用斧头砸碎别人脑袋的事情呢？那些东西在哪里？那才是好玩的部分。嗯，我的意思是，最明显的是，你拥有这些巨大的防御工事，它们是用
out of colossal, giant, Cyclopean boulders. And so there's a wonderful book on this whole process by a scholar called Cathy Gere about kind of the way that Mycenae has been understood. And she quotes a very distinguished scholar who says that the citadels, Mycenae and other such cities, served as symbols of the exalted status and the power of their rulers rather than as fortresses. And that even though these fortresses are marked by cycles of destruction and rebuilding and then destruction again, that actually this is due to earthquakes and not to violent conflict. So in a sense, it's standing the whole Schliemann-esque idea that he has found evidence for the Trojan War on its head. There was no Trojan War. The Mycenaeans were not kind of brutal warlords. It was all international trading and bureaucracy and weaving and so on. But it has to be said that I think the pendulum on that has swung back pretty hard. That kind of 60s idea that ancient peoples were all about beads and things. Right. You're not building those big walls just for fun. You're building them because there are some other people over the other hill who want to kill you. Right. And so Cathy Gere again quotes another scholar responding to this idea that the marks of
巨大的、巨型的、独眼巨人般的巨石建造的。关于整个过程，有一本很棒的书，作者是一位名叫凯西·吉尔的学者，她讲述了迈锡尼被理解的方式。她引用了一位非常杰出的学者的话，他说这些城堡，迈锡尼和其他类似的城市，是统治者崇高地位和权力的象征，而不是堡垒。即使这些堡垒经历了破坏、重建、再破坏的循环，实际上这是由于地震而不是暴力冲突造成的。所以从某种意义上说，这颠覆了施里曼式的观点，即他找到了特洛伊战争的证据。根本没有特洛伊战争。迈锡尼人也不是那种残暴的军阀。这一切都是国际贸易、官僚机构和纺织等等。但必须说，我认为这种观点已经发生了很大的逆转。那种60年代认为古代人民只关心珠子之类的想法。对。你建造那些大墙不仅仅是为了好玩。你建造它们是因为山那边有一些人想杀了你。对。所以凯西·吉尔再次引用了另一位学者的观点，回应了关于
destruction in Mycenaean cities were caused by earthquakes. She said, yeah, right. The building of massive Cyclopean walls is not a useful response to an earthquake. Yeah. Of course, I mean, you know, she's entirely true. What has been happening over the past decades, it's not exactly saying that Schliemann was right, that he'd found the Troy that was destroyed by the Greeks in the Trojan War, but that it is all rooted in much more solid foundations of historicity than perhaps people had thought about 40 or 50 years ago. And one of the key influences on this is that a whole load of texts from an empire to the east of Troy in what's now Turkey called the Hittite Empire, loads of these have been found.
迈锡尼城市中的破坏痕迹是由地震引起的说法。她说，是啊，没错。建造巨大的独眼巨人墙并不是应对地震的有效方法。是的，当然，你知道，她是完全正确的。过去几十年来发生的事情，并不是说施里曼是对的，他找到了被希腊人在特洛伊战争中摧毁的特洛伊，而是这一切都植根于比四五十年前人们所认为的更坚实的历史基础之上。其中一个关键的影响是，在特洛伊以东、现今土耳其境内的一个帝国，即赫梯帝国，发现了大量文本。
And they're being translated. The translation is ongoing. And it kind of portrays a world of great power politics that actually does seem to kind of meld with the idea of there having been a Trojan war. And it does suggest that perhaps Troy is a kind of buffer state between the empires of the Hittites and the empires of the Akiwawa, which might be the Achaeans, which is the name Homer gives to the Greeks in his epics, and that maybe that was what was going on. And I think also archaeology has demonstrated that the portrayal of Greek kingdoms in Homer does map onto the evidence from the Bronze Age. It does seem to be an authentic record of which
它们正在被翻译。翻译工作正在进行中。它描绘了一个大国政治的世界，这似乎确实与存在过特洛伊战争的想法相融合。这确实表明，也许特洛伊是赫梯帝国和阿基亚瓦帝国之间的一种缓冲国，阿基亚瓦可能是阿凯亚人，也就是荷马在史诗中给希腊人起的名字，也许这就是当时的情况。而且我认为考古学也证明了荷马对希腊王国的描绘确实与青铜时代的证据相吻合。它似乎确实是一份真实的记录，记录了哪些
cities were significant, which ones weren't. And we know from the tablets that these kingdoms were ruled by a man called a Wanax. And that's not so far from Homer's word Anax. So you can kind of see where the derivation of Agamemnon's title as Anax Andron, the ruler of men, that it might have come authentically from the Bronze Age. So that's the men. Yeah. What about the women? Yeah. What about Helen? Because, I mean, the women at the core of our story, having taken into account Schliemann and also the developments in academic thinking about all this, Tom, where are we with Helen
城市是重要的，哪些不是。我们从泥板上知道，这些王国由一个被称为“Wanax”的人统治。这与荷马的词“Anax”相差不远。所以你可以看出阿伽门农作为“Anax Andron”（人类统治者）的头衔的由来，它可能确实源自青铜时代。所以那是男人。是的。女人呢？是的。海伦呢？因为，我的意思是，考虑到施里曼以及学术界对此的所有发展，汤姆，我们对海伦
and with her sister Clytemnestra? So by far the most readable and enjoyable study of how Helen herself might have been rooted in memories of how women in the Bronze Age, Bronze Age queens might have lived, is Bethany Hughes's book on Helen of Troy, which I mentioned in the first episode. And she kind of makes her case at the opening of her book, because Helen is such an alluring figure of fantasy, because she dazzles as she goes, she can make it hard to see the women of substance who walked through the Bronze Age palaces of the Eastern Mediterranean. But ongoing archaeological and historical projects demonstrate that these women were prominent and significant. And I think she absolutely makes a case about that, you know, by going through the
和她的妹妹克吕泰涅斯特拉的看法如何？到目前为止，关于海伦本人如何可能植根于青铜时代女性、青铜时代王后生活方式的记忆，最可读、最令人愉快的研究是贝塔妮·休斯关于特洛伊海伦的书，我在第一集中提到过。她在书的开头就提出了她的观点，因为海伦是一个如此诱人的幻想人物，因为她所到之处光芒四射，这使得人们很难看到那些走过东地中海青铜时代宫殿的实质性女性。但正在进行的考古和历史项目证明，这些女性是杰出且重要的。我认为她绝对证明了这一点，你知道，通过梳理
evidence and looking specifically for evidence of queens. I mean, women like Helen and Clytemnestra are not apparent in, say, the 5th century BC. That's the whole point of Aeschylus' play, that the age where monstrous women like Clytemnestra could sway the destiny of a state, that is long gone in the past. But if you look back to the evidence in the Bronze Age, I think you do find that queens did have an elevated role. So, Bettany kind of adduces all kinds of evidence. So, Bettany's making the case specifically for Helen, and I think she does adduce fascinating evidence for how the traditions that are told about Helen might have originated in authentic Bronze Age practices. But just looking at it slightly broader before we zoom in on Helen. So looking at Mycenae,
证据并专门寻找王后的证据。我的意思是，像海伦和克吕泰涅斯特拉这样的女性在公元前5世纪并不明显。这就是埃斯库罗斯戏剧的全部意义所在，那个像克吕泰涅斯特拉这样的怪物女性可以左右国家命运的时代，早已成为过去。但如果你回顾青铜时代的证据，我认为你确实会发现王后确实拥有崇高的地位。所以，贝塔妮列举了各种各样的证据。所以，贝塔妮专门为海伦提出了论点，我认为她确实列举了迷人的证据，说明关于海伦的传说可能起源于真实的青铜时代习俗。但在我们聚焦海伦之前，先稍微广义地看一下。所以看看迈锡尼，
for instance, the home of Clytemnestra, it is absolutely clear from the archaeology that women were present in the citadel. And also that just as Clytemnestra is portrayed in Homer and in Aeschylus, they lived in unsegregated ways. So Agamemnon and Clytemnestra could absolutely be imagined going into the bathroom together as Aeschylus portrays them. And we know that because their artefacts are found together and they're buried together, things like that? Well, there's one room in particular in Mycenae where there's evidence of weaving. So that is a marker of women, but there are also kind of arrowheads there.
例如，克吕泰涅斯特拉的家，考古学清楚地表明女性出现在城堡中。而且，正如克吕泰涅斯特拉在荷马和埃斯库罗斯笔下所描绘的那样，她们的生活方式是不隔离的。所以阿伽门农和克吕泰涅斯特拉完全可以被想象成一起走进浴室，正如埃斯库罗斯所描绘的那样。我们知道这一点是因为他们的文物被一起发现，他们被埋在一起，诸如此类？嗯，迈锡尼有一个特别的房间，有纺织的证据。所以那是女性的标志，但那里也有箭头。
Oh, right. Okay. So that suggests a kind of mixing of male and female going on. Yeah. And as you say, also, there is no segregation in death. So these shaft graves excavated by Schliemann, there are female bodies as well as male bodies. Although the women don't have masks, they kind of have strips of gold diadems on their heads. And kind of broadening
哦，对。好的。所以这表明男女之间存在某种混合。是的。而且正如你所说，死亡中也没有隔离。所以这些由施里曼挖掘的竖井墓中，既有女性尸体也有男性尸体。虽然女性没有面具，但她们的头上戴着金色的头带。而且稍微扩展一下
it out to look at kind of some of the things that you get in Homeric epic. So the idea that the abduction of women might be a cause for war, there seems to be evidence for that in some of the Hittite tablets. There's definitely evidence for high-ranking women being used as diplomatic tools or trading chips. They're commodities to be passed from great kingdom to great kingdom. If you think of the passage that I read about Clytemnestra weaving this kind of voluminous shroud that traps Agamemnon so he can then be butchered, he gets kind of hacked to death in the bath. You also have Helen is described in the Iliad as kind of embroidering a great purple robe. And of course, very famously, Penelope, the wife of Odysseus, while she's waiting for her
看看荷马史诗中的一些内容：关于绑架女性可能成为战争起因的想法，在一些赫梯泥板中似乎有证据。绝对有证据表明高地位女性被用作外交工具或交易筹码。她们是可以在大王国之间传递的商品。如果你想到我读到的关于克吕泰涅斯特拉编织那种巨大的裹尸布来困住阿伽门农，以便他随后被屠杀的段落，他在浴室里被砍死。你在《伊利亚特》中也看到海伦被描述为在绣一件巨大的紫色长袍。当然，非常著名的是，奥德修斯的妻子佩涅洛佩，在她等待
husband to return, she's weaving and then unpicking her cloth all the way to try and keep her suitors at bay. And this image of great women at the head of weavers, of servant girls, this again, there's absolutely evidence for this in the tablets that have survived from the Bronze Age palaces like Mycenae. And so linear B is it's, it's much more like Chinese or hieroglyphs. It's not a, it's not an alphabet. The image for a woman is you have two dots for a breast. You have kind of arms sticking out. You have what's clearly a skirt and you have what seems to be a kind of curl of hair. So for a man, it's a straight line. You know, he's had his haircut. For a woman, it's a kind of curve, like it's a braid or something. And all of this seems to kind of gel with what you get in Homer, the portrayal of great women and their ranks of servants. Now, what about Helen herself? So this is the evidence, among lots of other evidence, that Bettany uses for
丈夫归来时，她一直在编织然后拆掉她的布，试图以此来阻挡她的追求者。这种伟大的女性作为织工、侍女之首的形象，在从迈锡尼等青铜时代宫殿中幸存下来的泥板中绝对有证据。所以线性文字B，它更像中文或象形文字。它不是字母表。女性的图像是你有两个点代表乳房。你有伸出的手臂。你有很明显的裙子，还有看起来像是一卷头发的东西。所以对于男人，它是一条直线。你知道，他剪了头发。对于女人，它是一种曲线，就像辫子之类的。所有这些似乎都与你在荷马作品中看到的关于伟大女性及其侍女行列的描绘相吻合。现在，海伦本人呢？所以这就是贝塔妮用来证明
the memories of Helen being rooted in Bronze Age ideals of beauty. So we talked about how Helen is described as Xanthe. Golden head. Golden head, or redhead perhaps. And Bettany points out that on the island of Thera, the great volcanic eruption. Yeah, modern day Santorini. That set a tsunami overwhelming Crete, which is one of the theories for where the story of Atlantis came from. And it buried these frescoes a bit like Pompeii. And there are lots of portraits of aristocratic women on it. And most of them, they have have dark hair but there are people with lighter hair and she points out that there is one in particular who has red hair these are women close to the the image of a deity and that this woman is closest to the deity and most of the mortals don't wear
海伦的记忆植根于青铜时代审美理想的证据之一。所以我们谈到了海伦如何被描述为“Xanthe”。金发。金发，或者也许是红发。贝塔妮指出，在圣托里尼岛，那次巨大的火山爆发。是的，现代的圣托里尼。那引发了一场海啸淹没了克里特岛，这是亚特兰蒂斯故事来源的理论之一。它像庞贝城一样掩埋了这些壁画。上面有很多贵族女性的肖像。她们大多数人都有深色的头发，但也有头发较浅的人，她指出其中有一个特别的人有红头发，这些女性接近神灵的形象，而且这个女人最接近神灵，大多数凡人不戴
a necklace the necklace seems to be a symbol for a god but that this particular mortal the one with the red hair she is wearing a necklace so perhaps there's a kind of implication there that to have red or golden hair is somehow seen as a marker of kind of semi divine status right you know i mean it's a fascinating theory there is we we described how helen is always described as being kind of white like the shell of the egg from which she emerged and um lots of white lead oxide has been found which seems to have been used as kind of cosmetics so um to quote bethany the overall effect is mesmerizing women made up in this way have great impact they become walking effigies their faces take on the appearance of a mask. Their painted bodies move from the natural to the supernatural. So again, very, very potent.
项链，项链似乎是神的象征，但这个特定的凡人，那个红头发的女人，她戴着项链，所以也许这里有一种暗示，即拥有红发或金发在某种程度上被视为半神地位的标志，对吧？你知道，我的意思是，这是一个迷人的理论。我们描述了海伦总是被描述为像她从中破壳而出的蛋壳一样白，而且发现了大量的白色氧化铅，这似乎被用作化妆品，所以，引用贝塔妮的话，整体效果令人着迷。以这种方式化妆的女性具有巨大的影响力。她们变成了行走的雕像，她们的脸呈现出面具的样子。她们涂了颜料的身体从自然转向超自然。所以再次强调，非常、非常有力。
And I think that, I mean, obviously it's not conclusive, but it's interesting enough, I think, to satisfy the yearning that, oh no, I've always wanted it to be true. So what all that is suggesting is that the portrait of Helen, it's not saying that somebody called Helen existed. No. But it's basically saying the portrait that you get of a golden haired princess, very powerful. She lives in a world of servants and weavers. She moves through the palace. She's wearing white makeup to whiten her features.
我认为，我的意思是，显然这不是决定性的，但我认为它足够有趣，可以满足那种“哦不，我一直希望它是真的”的渴望。所以所有这些都表明，海伦的肖像，并不是说一个叫海伦的人真的存在。不。但它基本上是说，你得到的那个金发公主的肖像，非常强大。她生活在一个有仆人和织工的世界里。她在宫殿里走动。她涂着白色的化妆品来美白她的特征。
Yeah. And she might be used as kind of a chip in international relations. Yeah, she might be sent away or there might be some breakdown in negotiations in which possession of her becomes a political controversy. And also she wears a necklace that suggests that she might end up occupying a position that has a hint of the divine about it. And that's what Helen is ultimately representing. So when the story first begins, to its first listeners,
是的。而且她可能被用作国际关系中的一种筹码。是的，她可能会被送走，或者谈判可能会破裂，导致对她的占有成为政治争议。而且她还戴着一条项链，暗示她最终可能会占据一个带有神性暗示的位置。这就是海伦最终所代表的。所以当故事刚开始时，对于第一批听众来说，
because of course it's an oral tradition, isn't it, with these stories initially, to the first listeners, she would be an immediately recognizable figure as a Bronze Age queen. I mean, the thing is, we haven't really done an episode on the historicity of the Trojan War generally. But I mean, there is no question that there are fragments of language and of authentic elements of the Bronze Age world preserved in Homer. And I think the idea that the portrayal of Queens, so like Helen, like Clytemnestra, in Homer, that that preserves a memory that is true to the Bronze Age palaces, I think is not beyond the bounds of possibility. What about, as we move towards the end, what about this idea that I guess a lot of feminist critics have advanced? I mean, there's this huge trend,
因为当然这是一个口头传统，不是吗，这些故事最初是这样的，对于第一批听众来说，她会是一个立刻就能认出的青铜时代王后形象。我的意思是，问题是，我们还没有真正做过关于特洛伊战争历史真实性的一般性节目。但我的意思是，毫无疑问，荷马中保留了青铜时代世界的语言碎片和真实元素。而且我认为，荷马中对王后（如海伦、克吕泰涅斯特拉）的描绘保留了符合青铜时代宫殿的真实记忆，我认为这并非不可能。当我们接近尾声时，关于我想很多女性主义批评家提出的那个想法，你怎么看？我的意思是，现在在小说和文学小说中，重写希腊神话有一个巨大的趋势，
obviously, now in fiction and literary fiction for rewriting the Greek myths and rewriting them, you know, often women writers who are rewriting them from a female's perspective, maybe giving female characters more agency or talking about the sexual violence that they suffer and all that kind of thing. Where do you think Helen and Clytemnestra stand? Because clearly for the Greeks who heard those stories, they were very unsettling figures. And you could, of course, argue from our perspective that if you're a woman listening to that, presumably you're very conscious of the way in which they are objectified, their sexuality is seen as something dangerous and deadly. And that is the beginning of aical tradition of casting her as a victim of rape denies
显然，通常是女性作家从女性的角度重写它们，也许赋予女性角色更多的主动权，或者谈论她们遭受的性暴力等等。你认为海伦和克吕泰涅斯特拉处于什么位置？因为对于听到这些故事的希腊人来说，她们显然是非常令人不安的人物。当然，你可以从我们的角度争辩说，如果你是一个听这些故事的女性，你大概非常清楚她们被物化的方式，她们的性被视为某种危险和致命的东西。这就是将她塑造成强奸受害者的传统开始，这否认了
her the agency that she has if she decides she's fed up with Menelaus. She's going to take her golden treasure and go off and hitch up with Paris. I think that Clytemnestra is clearly seen as a monstrous and terrifying figure, but she completely dominates Aeschylus' tragedy. I mean, she is by far the most powerful figure within it. And you could say that that is an expression of the nightmares of Aeschylus' audience, because in Athens, women don't have any form of political power, but they do have a role as mediators between the state of Athens and the gods. And Clytemnestra might serve as a kind of warning of what happens if women ignore that
如果她决定厌倦了墨涅拉俄斯，她所拥有的主动权。她要带着她的金银财宝离开，去和帕里斯在一起。我认为克吕泰涅斯特拉显然被视为一个怪物和可怕的人物，但她完全主宰了埃斯库罗斯的悲剧。我的意思是，她是其中最强大的角色。你可以说这是埃斯库罗斯观众噩梦的表达，因为在雅典，女性没有任何形式的政治权力，但她们确实扮演着雅典城邦与神灵之间调解人的角色。而克吕泰涅斯特拉可能起到了一种警告作用，即如果女性忽视了那个
role. I mean, Greek tragedy is full of very, very powerful women. And it does seem that the power of those women is a kind of expression of anxieties that are kind of inherent. These are women who've got above themselves? Is that basically what you're saying? I don't think it's above themselves. It's the notion that the proper order of things, as the Athenians of the 5th century BC understand them, that it threatens catastrophe and disaster. And that's why the cycle of revenge and bloodshed
角色会发生什么。我的意思是，希腊悲剧充满了非常、非常强大的女性。而且这些女性的力量似乎确实是一种内在焦虑的表达。这些是那些自视甚高的女性吗？你基本上是这个意思吗？我不认为这是自视甚高。这是一种观念，即按照公元前5世纪雅典人所理解的事物的正常秩序，它威胁着灾难和毁灭。这就是为什么复仇和流血的循环
that Clytemnestra is involved in, the fact that it is settled by the virgin figure of Athena, who is of course herself female, but in the context of Athens is so important. Because Athena is indisputably powerful, but she's not killing people and overthrowing them, although traditionally she always has done. But it's a very specific vision of the role that women and men should properly play. And I think with Helen, I mean, she's incredibly powerful. She is terrifying. And it's the quality of all the heroes in Greek myth that they are powerful. And Socrates, I think, you know, is putting his finger on something very significant about those myths when he says
克吕泰涅斯特拉所卷入的，事实上它是由雅典娜的处女形象解决的，她本人当然也是女性，但在雅典的背景下非常重要。因为雅典娜无疑是强大的，但她并没有杀人并推翻他们，尽管传统上她总是这样做。但这是一种关于女性和男性应该扮演什么角色的非常具体的愿景。我认为对于海伦，我的意思是，她非常强大。她是可怕的。希腊神话中所有英雄的品质都是他们很强大。我认为苏格拉底在说
that beauty is more powerful than strength. Yeah, I think he's right. So thank you for that, Tom. That was absolutely fascinating. Loads of things that we can come back to maybe in the rest of this history. So the Trojan War, the story of Schliemann, Greek gods and Greek heroes more generally. And on that bombshell, we will see you next week. Bye bye. Bye bye. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde.
美比力量更强大时，确实指出了这些神话中非常重要的一点。是的，我认为他是对的。所以谢谢你，汤姆。这绝对令人着迷。也许在我们这段历史的其余部分中，我们可以回到很多事情上。所以特洛伊战争，施里曼的故事，希腊神话和更广泛的希腊英雄。带着这个重磅消息，我们下周见。再见。再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the rest of There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《其余皆娱乐》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论和一点演艺圈八卦的来源。在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开了娱乐业的幕布，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和现场门票的优先购买权，请前往The Rest Is。目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。